ينضم الينا من الخرطوم يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوه الدعم السريع اهلا بك
معنا استاذ يوسف مره جديده في تغطيه
العربيه المستمره للاحداث في السودان هل
يمكن ان تؤكدوا لنا هذا الكلام الذي
نقلناه عن وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان
الاتفاق من حيث المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه
ايام تبدا من يوم الخميس المقبل
حقيقه الامر ليس اعلنت وزاره وزاره
الخارجيه جنوب السودان نحن
علاقتنا بجنوب السودان علاقه طيبه هي دوله
كانت جنوب جزء مننا ونحترم قيادتها
سلفاكير رئيس الفاكر لكن الاعلان عن
موافقه سابق لاوانا نحن تلقينا اتصال
وتلقينا رساله مكتوبه من جنوب السودان
وقلنا لهم اذا لم يستطع البرهان
الوفاء بسته هدى وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش
هدنه معلنه والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف
مواقعنا لم يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن
لاوانه ان ان ان ان
لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه
اختبار الحقيقي هو الالتزام بهذه الهدنه
وقد اعلن قائد قوات الدعم السريع في اكثر
من موقف انه مستعد حتى لو وقف اطلاق النار
اذا كان البرهان يسيطر على الجيش اذا كان
يستطيع الوفاه بتعهداته فهو يعلم تعهدات
امام المجتمع الدولي لاكثر من سته ولم
يلتزموا واحده الطيران كل الشعب السوداني
كل العالم يرى ان الطيران يقصف مواقع
مواقعنا ويدمر مستشفيات ويدمر احياء ويضرب
بيوت هذه فوضى
ولكن يعني قبل ان ندخل في موضوع الاتهامات
المتبادله اذا انت الان تنفي موافقه قوات
الدعم السريعه على هدنه اسبوع او وقف
اطلاق نار لاسبوع ابتداء من اليوم الخميس
المقبل
نعم نعم لم نوافق على هدنه لمده اسبوع نحن
اشترطنا اذا نجح البرهان
او يمكننا الحديث
حتى ولكنكم كنتم توافقون على الهدن
المتتاليه ولو لثلاثه ايام ما الذي يمنع
الان من الموافقه على تمديد هدنه لسبعه
ايام نحن موافق ولكن اي دائما هذه الهدن
النظارات جميعا السودان ليس
منطقه
خاليه من الستلايت الشعب السوداني يرى
فنحن الجيش ليس لديه مشاعل للارض نحن
نسيطر على مواقعنا ولا نتحرك منها ولا
نواجه بهجوم اخر هجوم للجيش
في
منطقه في متحرك قدم من كردفان وتم التصدي
له وهزيمته نحن نسيطر على مداخل الخرطوم
كلها لا ليس هنالك حركه مشاه في الخرطوم
كل الذي يحدث هو قصف مدفعي وطيران يقوم
ويخصفه ويسبب اضرار كل الشعب السوداني
يراه منقوله على السوشيال ميديا
من الذي يخلق الهدنه ولكن الجيش يتهمكم
باتخاذ بعض الاماكن بالناس الذين فيها
دروعا بشريه باحتلال مستشفيات باجبار ناس
على اخلاء منازلهم بالسيطره على مواقع
معينه وهو الجيش الحامي الحمى القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه ويريد ان يقوم
بدوره بالتالي اليس كذلك يا اخي يا اخي
هذا حديث حديث اصبح مكررا اصبح غير غير لا
يمكن تصديقه الجيش اتهمنا اننا دخلنا
مستشفى الخرطوم وحولناها لسكنه عسكريه
وادخلنا سلاح اثبت الاطباء وباتصالات في
صفحاتهم انهم ما قالوا يمارسون اعمالهم
الطبيعيه في مستشفى الخرطوم على
مستشفى
العمليات يعالج فيه من الجيش والدعم
السريع بالامس وصف
قم للمستشفى
اعلى هذه كلها يعني تضليل للراي العام
محاوله الانتصارات وهميه الاداره لعمليات
في شاشات انا اسال الجيش واسال الذين
يقومون عليه
تريد من هل تريدون اغناء الشعب السوداني
الذي يرى الذي نقوم بحمايته نحن فتحنا
الاسواق في ام درمان وحميناها وفتحنا
الاسواق في حمله كوكو فتحنا الاسواق في
كوبر
كله حمايه الدعم السريع كل المواطنين
يعرفون ذلك وينظرون الى ذلك علنا نحن لا
نتخذ المواطنين دروعا بشريه باعتبار اننا
موجودين في ارتكازات في كل الكباري
المؤديه منه الى الخرطوم موجودين
يعني انت تعرف بياناته اكثر منا ويقول
بانه هو المسيطر على البلاد ولو انه الوضع
يعني في بعض مناطق الخرطوم انتم لا تزالون
تسيطرون عليها الا ان الوضع مستقر وهو
الذي لا يزال يمسك بزمام الامور
العاده بعض احاديث سيد حميدتي بالامس فسرت
على انه فيها نوع من انواع التراجع بسبب
حديثه عن ما سماه خيانه ضباط له وعن اعداد
يعني من القتلى والجرحى في صفوفه
لا انا اقول لك شيء يمكنك الاتصال عشوائيا
على اي رقم في الخرطوم اسال المواطنين من
الذي موجود في في الشارع من الذي موجود في
ارتكازات من الذي يحميهم من الذي يطارد
اللصوص من الذي يحمل البيوت التي تركها
اصحابها وذهبوا الى الولايات نحن نقوم
بدورنا وموجودين على
الجيش يوجد في السماء يضرب عشوائيا لكن
عمليا على الارض تس
ونالك موجوده للجيش معروفه لا داعي لاضرب
رقم لا اعرفه نحن نتحدث الى صحفيين ونحن
يعني قناه لنا كثير من الناس على الارض
ويقولون بوضوح وليس فقط الى صحفيين الى
محللين سياسيين الى ضباط الى لواءات
سابقين في الجيش ويتحدثون عن عمليات نهب
وسلب ترتكبها قوات الدعم السريع عن احتلال
منازل عن قنص عن فوضى في عدد من المناطق
وليس فقط في المناطق الاساسيه التي نتحدث
عنها يوميا يا اخي نحن ندعو الصحفيين
الذين يتحدثون وندعي كمراتكم ان ناخذهم في
جوله على كل المناطق التي نسافر عليها وهي
مناطق واسعه وقنعه ونستطيع الان تامين
حياه اي صحفي يريد ان يرى بكاميرته ويسجل
الواقع اننا نسمع هذه الدعايه في الاعلام
لكن نحن نعيش وسط الناس وموجودين ولدينا
لجان احياء نتعامل معها هنالك تشكيل لجان
احيا في معظم
احياء العمل
بس انتم غير قادرين على حمايه انفسكم لان
تريدون حمايه صحفيين يعني هذا كلام مرسل
نحن هذا الاسبوع الثالث اذا لم نكن قادرين
على حمايه انفسنا ليه ما صمدنا امام جيش
عمره 100 عام كم عدد القتلى من قوات الدعم
السريع وعدد الجرحى وعدد من انشق عنكم
وعاد الى صفوف الجيش وعدد من اسر
دعني اقول لك شيء في اليوم الاول للعمليات
نعم الطيران ضرب الناس وهم غير مسلحين في
معسكر كرري
امام المبادره لا اقول لك ليس لدينا شهداء
نعم لدينا شهداء ولكن اسال الجيش كم متحرك
متحرك النيل العزل متح
ركه هنا واضباطه معنا الغائب محمد حمدان
حين اتكلم عن خيانه
الضباط لا يتحدث عن ضباط الدعم السريع
الذين هم من صلب الدعم السريع
منتدبين الى الدعم السريع والمكلفين
بقياده القوات بعد اصدار البرهان لغرارهم
بالغاء الانتداب الى الدعم السريع
الضباط للجيش باعتبارا لهم يتبعون للجيش
اصلا اصلا لا يتبعون لنا نحن بمنتدبين في
اطار ان القوات الدعم السريه كانت جزء من
فهذا امر تجاوزناه ونحن الان في الاسبوع
الثالث لدينا قياده ميدانيه لدينا شعبه
عمليات لدينا طريقه عملنا استطيع ان
الصمود يستطيعنا ان نصب هجمات طيران
نستطيع اذا بناء على كل ذلك لماذا لا
توافقون على هدنه من سبعه ايام كما تحدثت
خارجيه جنوب السودان ما الذي يمنع يا اخي
نحن نتعامل مع قوه
بالهدنه ليس لدينا مانع جهودا جديده لكن
لابد ان تكون هنالك جهه ما تقول من خلق
الهدنه لا يمكن ان تطلبني ان اوافق على
هدنه
انه ولا
تهمان بعضهم البعض بخرق الهدنه ولكن الان
هل انتم مستعدون لارسال
الممثل الذي عين من اجل البدء بمفاوضات
ولو كانت فنيه ولو سمها ما شئت
معنا الان ندرس عده نغدر مبادر الجنوب
السودان لدينا مبادره المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه ابدينا ملاحظات وابدينا اراءنا
ومن حيث المبدا نرى انها يمكن ان تعود الى
الى حل مازلنا ندرس عدد من المبادرات
الاخرى ما دلنا على تواصل مع الجامعه
العربيه والاتحاد الافريقي وكل المنظمات
مازلنا نتواصل معلومه من المتحده نحن نريد
هدنه او ايقاف نار يوقف الحرف السوداني
الى الابد هذه الحرف لها جذور هذه الحرب
ليست فدائيه هذه الحرب فيها خطاب لا يتفق
وواقع السودان على هدنه من سبعه ايام اولا
ومن ثم تتكثف الاتصالات للبدء بالجلوس على
طاوله التفاوض ومن
ثم نحن الان في هدنه فليلتزم
الجيش بهذه الهدنه
فاذا شخص
هناك هدنه معروضه عليكم ما مشكلتكم حتى لو
لم يلتزم ما مشكلتكم في تجديد الهدنه
والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات تتحدثون عن
ملاحظات ما هي ملاحظاتكم هذه
نحن من جنوب السودان
روي الهدنه ونحن اصلا
ما هي ملاحظاتكم انس جنوب السودان الان لو
تكرمت
ملاحظاتنا
التزمنا التزمنا بالهدنه التي اقترحوها
لمده ثلاثه ايام جددناها مره اخرى لمده
ثلاثه ايام ونحن هذه اللحظه نعيش يهودنا
وما زال
واحده من شروطنا ان يستطيع البرهان للجلوس
معه وتوقيع وقته اطلاق نار او توضيح هدنه
ممتده بمراقبي عليه ان يثبت خلال سته هدى
انه يستطيع ايقافه
متعدده الان اليوم خرج خرج ياسر العطا وهو
عموما السياده في الجيش يقول انه لا علم
له اصلا بكل ما يجري لا هذا الراجع الحدث
راجع التلفزيون الحدث العربيه الحدث هو
قال
وا وهذا الرجل رجل التالي في الجيش يقول
انه لا يلتزم بوفيه الاغنار ولا علم له
حتى بالموافقه على المبادره الامريكيه
يبدو ان الجيش
مع يبدو ان القيادات الجيش لا تسيطر على
الواقع
نحن نشك ان هناك جهه اخرى سيطرت على الجيش
هي التي تحرك نعود هنا الى اتهامات سيطره
ضباط اسلاميين على الجيش
هذا اتهامكم الدائم ولكن لا يبدو انه
سودانيين يعني
بمختلف اطيافهم
يصدقون مثل هذا الكلام بل شرائح كبيره
منهم تقف الى جانب قواتهم المسلحه وباتت
تنظر الى قوات الدعم السريعه على انها
ميليشيات متفلته
هذا راي لا يوجد قياس راعي للشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني مزاجه العام نحن نتواصل مع
كل الشعب السوداني موجودين نحنا من رحنا
الشعب السوداني نعرف موقف الشعب السوداني
من الحرب
ونعرف تفكير الشعب السوداني في في عمليه
السلم هؤلاء الذين يتحدثون باسم الشعب
السوداني لا علاقه لهم معروفون لديهم
انتماءاتهم السياسيه معروفون لديهم جزء
نظرتهم للجيش لانه يحمي مصالحهم هذه هذه
الفئه لا تمثل الشعب السوداني الشعب
السوداني لم يست
طع احد قياس رايه نحن نعيش وسط الشعب
السود
اني خروجه الشعب السوداني للولايات من
اراد ان يذهب
الشعب السوداني يقف مع من لم يعد بعده ولا
نريد الشعب السوداني ايضا
مؤيد للجيش هذا انقسام اليهود الى الى
انقسام كبير في الشعب السوداني
ملاحظه اخرى من ملاحظاتكم لو سمحت
مفهوم مفهوم بس ملاحظه اخرى او او اثنتين
على يعني مبادره المقدمه الان من السعوديه
ما هي ملاحظاتكم الاخرى قلت لي التزام
البرهان فقط
بالهدنه ماذا ايضا نحن اتينا ايجابا مع
هذه المبادره تعطينا وتواصلنا مع الجهات
التي طرحتها امريكا مع السعوديه ارسلنا
لهم ردا مكتوبا تعطينا ايجابيه مع هذه
المبادره وما زلنا نراهن على انها تستطيع
اذا اذا استطاع التوسيع المنبر تستطيع ان
توقف الح
رب ايضا ليست في اطلاق النار مرتبط بغضايا
سياسيه مرتبط بمصالح للشعب السوداني مرتبط
بشل هذه العصابه مره واحده والى الابد ان
تؤثر في في تعطيل مسار السودان الديمقراطي
الذي عطلته 30 سنه ان تساهم في في في في
نهب خيرات الشعب السوداني
في هذه المفاوضات او في هذه المبادره
الوصول الى حل شامل حتى بما فيها القضايا
السياسيه وليس فقط وقفه اطلاق النار ونعم
المشكله السوداني كلهم هذه قضيه الحربه
التي ندخلها الان او التي نواجهها الان هي
ليست حرب عسكريه
باختلاف قاعدين او
دعمتها وابت لها وتقوده لابد ان يكون
هنالك حل سياسي لكل لصالح كل الشعب
السوداني
من الاطراف الذين تتواصلون معهم عندما
قلتم بانه هذه هي ملاحظاتنا
نعم هنالك دراسه لتلك الملاحظات وهنالك
ردود وهنالك تشجيع على ان هنالك ستكون
ضمانات لانجاح المبادره وما زال الحوار
مستمر متى يمكن ان نسمع شيئا من هذا
القبيل الاجابه واضحه التزاما واضحا كم
اعطيتموهم مهله وقت مثلا لكي يلتزم الطرف
الاخر بوقف القتال من اجل ان توافقوا على
هدنه جديده مطوله
سابق يوم الغد ولم يلتزم بها الطرف الثاني
ولا ثانيه واحده وهذه الهدنه ما زالت
مستمره وما زالت قواتنا في ارتكازاتها لم
تحرك اليه واحده من مكان الى مكان نحن
ننزل الامس ننزل التزام قبل الامس لان
الهدنه قبلها كانت فتنه وتم تمديدها لم
نحرك اي اليه الا في اطار الخدمات العاديه
لم نهاجم اي اي قوات مسلحه ولا نهاجم اي
موقع غير المواقع التي نسيطر عليها نحن ما
زلنا ملتزمين وعلى الطرف الثاني ان يوقف
ضرب الطيران يعني لا يوجد شيء اخر غير
الطيران هو الذي يهدد حياه المواطنين لا
ليس للجيش مشعل على الارض شكرا جزيلا لك
من الخرطوم يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات